hey this is presh talwalkar
on january 22nd 2018 facebook open
source tweeted the following
we've launched flicks a unit of time
slightly larger than a nanosecond that
exactly subdivides media frame rates and
sampling frequencies
the story caught the media's attention
from the verge facebook announces that
it has invented a new unit of time
from techcrunch
facebook invented a new time unit called
the flick and it's truly amazing
from the bbc
facebook invents new unit of time called
a flick
i think the most accurate headline goes
to rs technica
oculus creates a new open source unit of
time to measure frame rates
oculus is a vr subdivision of facebook
and perhaps the most misleading title i
saw was from the daily mail
in all capital letters
what are facebook flicks
the new measure of time invented by mark
zuckerberg
i should mention it's an incorrect title
because the flick was developed by
christopher horvath and others through a
discussion started in late 2016 which
you can actually see the facebook post
where they were discussing it
now there's one detail that could not
have been encapsulated in headlines is
that ntsc variations are variable frame
rates and they'll be handled by
approximate frame rates which can then
be represented exactly in flicks
so flick is short for frame tick
and it's a unit of time that can exactly
divide many common rates for video frame
rates and audio sampling frequencies
now the unit of a frequency is a hertz
abbreviated hc and that's one cycle per
second
so common video rates vary from 24 hertz
to 120 hertz
we can convert these hertz into frames
per second
and if we wanted to subdivide these into
one 1000 subdivisions we would multiply
each of these by a thousand
common audio sampling rates are measured
in kilohertz these are samples per
second and they range from 8 kilohertz
to 192 kilohertz these are some of the
common ones
to convert from kilohertz into hertz
we'll multiply each of these numbers by
a thousand
and here we go
so
we want the smallest frequency that will
evenly divide all of these numbers in
order that we can sync
frame rates of videos and audio sampling
rates
so what number would evenly divide all
of these numbers
well using brute force we can calculate
its 705 million six hundred thousand
and from this number the unit of flick
could be defined as one over this which
is approximately 1.41
nanoseconds
now what's interesting for me is that we
can actually derive this number using
basic number theory and that's what i
want to go through in the rest of the
video
so where does this mysterious number
seven hundred and five million six
hundred thousand come from
let's figure it out
so we start out with these frame rates
and sampling rates and we want the
smallest frequency that will divide all
of these numbers so what is that
well mathematically we're talking about
the least common multiple of all of
these numbers
so how can we get the least common
multiple of this gigantic list of
numbers
well it actually turns out to be
something not too difficult for us to
calculate
we can simplify the calculation by
eliminating any smaller number that's a
factor of a larger number
for example 192 000 has factors of eight
thousand sixteen thousand twenty four
thousand thirty two thousand forty eight
thousand and ninety six thousand
so we can eliminate all of these smaller
numbers from the list because the least
common multiple will at least be as
large as this largest number
we can do the same thing for some of
these other numbers in the list
and when we do that we end up
eliminating actually quite a bit of this
list
so we only end up with five different
numbers and we need to figure out the
lcm of these five numbers
one way that we can do that is by taking
the prime factorization of each of these
numbers
now in order to figure out the least
common multiple
we take the highest power of each prime
in this list
so we have 2 to the power of 9
3 squared
5 to the power of 5 and 7 squared
we multiply each of these together to
get the least common multiple
and the number we get is
705 million six hundred thousand
so we know
that this is the number of flicks that
we want in one second
therefore
the unit of time a flick will be one
divided by this number
and this will be approximately 1.417
nanoseconds
with this unit of time
we can then convert to all of these
common frame rates in terms of flicks
and it'll be an exact integer number
so it'll allow us to exactly
define each of these frame rates and
possibly convert and sync between them
without any problems
so it's a pretty interesting concept of
time
and it's interesting how the number
theory comes into play in deriving this
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon
if you have a suggestion for a puzzle or
another future math topic you can email
me at presh
mindyourdecisions.com you can also catch
me on social media either at
mindyourdecisions or at presh talwalkar